how's it going everyone it's Warren and
today I have a very awesome and special
video for you as I have an exclusive MCU
scoop every now and then I get lucky and
get an exclusive scoop from somebody
that's on the inside and today is one of
those days a scoop that involves certain
characters making their MCU debut in a
way that you would have never thought
and this is coming right after Marvel
Studios as President Kevin Feige has
mentioned that they are introducing some
new characters in Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness that we would have
never expected in a way that we would
never expect either so we're going to
talk about who these characters are why
they're being introduced in the MCU in
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness and what effect their
introduction to the MCU is going to have
on the future be sure to subscribe when
notifications turned on leave a like and
drop a comment on the video to enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 so today's exclusive scoop
comes from Mikey Sutton many of you have
heard me mention Mikey before he's
dropped a lot of inside scoops for our
community including when Spiderman was
going to be introduced into the MCU in
Captain America Civil War and he
reported that Disney and Sony were still
working out a deal even though they said
they weren't and this is the first part
of the scoop that Mikey's been so kind
to let me drop today there are
dimensions beyond which are known to man
and there's one MCU superhero who
specializes in journeying into these
Twilight zones in Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness Marvel Studios
dives headlong into the psychedelic
reality warps of Steve Ditko aiming for
the otherworldly terrors of HP Lovecraft
involving extraterrestrial landscapes
that the Avengers are not accustomed to
Doctor Strange will need a group of new
guardians that will protect Earth from
the portal that the Scarlet Witch ripped
wide open for the otherworldly terrors
to invade our planet according to inside
sources close to Mikey Sutton Doctor
Strange will end up forming the
Illuminati a secret organization of
highly intelligent and powerful
individuals at the end of Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness this
mysterious collective will include Reed
Richards aka mr. fantastic of the
Fantastic Four and Professor X of the
x-men this being planned to make his MCU
debut in Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness Mikey says to
please keep in mind that this Intel's
from private conversations that
transpired before pre productions
any changes that have happened since our
unknown from this information though
Professor X will make his first MCU
appearance and Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness
who else is being developed for the
Illuminati you can head over to the
Lords of the long box YouTube channel
for part two of the exclusive Mikey
Sutton scoop but let's break down this
insanely awesome scoop to start off
Kevin Feige and Marvel Studios have been
planning on introducing the mutants to
the MCU for over 10 years since the very
first Iron Man movie and we have
evidence of this in an exclusive deleted
scene that Kevin Feige shared with us
Nick Fury when talking to Tony Stark
about the Avengers initiative literally
named drops mutants and assorted mutants
weren't enough I have to deal with a
spoiled brat who doesn't play well with
others and wants to keep all this toys
to himself the very young Nick Fury
director of shield I'm here to talk to
you about the Avenger initiative Oh what
are we avenging whatever the hell we
want
so Professor X mr. fantastic and the
Illuminati for those of you who are not
aware of what Marvel's Illuminati is let
me explain why this is simply amazing
news the original marvel's Illuminati
group was formed by some of the most
elite superheroes in the Marvel Universe
they're a secret organization comprised
of the sorcerer supreme
dr. strange king of the Inhumans Black
Bolt the founder of the x-men Charles
Xavier or Professor X the founding
member of the Fantastic Four Reed
Richards or mr. fantastic the king of
Atlantis Namor the Submariner and Tony
Stark one of the founding members of the
Avengers so as you can see a very
powerful and stacked group of
superheroes originally this group was
formed by Tony Stark uniting all of
these people along with Black Panther in
Wakanda shortly after the crease Ghul
Ward that had earth involved black
panther would end up choosing not to
join the group but the original idea
suggested by Tony Stark was that they
form a mega group consisting of all the
superhero teams and groups so the
Avengers
the x-men the Inhumans etc but
eventually the group was scaled down to
a small secret group that would share
secret information and decide secretly
how all of the individual groups would
correspond to threats so this actually
makes perfect sense how the Illuminati
would form right now in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right after the
events of Avengers endgame and
specifically after the events that are
going to take place in one division
because as Mikey said in this scoop
apparently in the one division series
The Scarlet Witch is going to rip open a
portal and apparently earth is going to
be experiencing some extra dimensional
threats and keep in mind there isn't
really an Avengers team right now
immediately following Avengers endgame
the main members are either gone or
retired there's no more Tony Stark
there's no more Captain America no more
black widow yes some of the other
Avengers are going to be coming back but
not right away
so Doctor Strange is going to be needing
some help and that help is going to come
from outside superhero groups the
Fantastic Four and the x-men and Doctor
Strange is going to take the leaders of
these groups and form the Illuminati now
one thing to mention which is really
really important is that there actually
is a president's for the Illuminati to
come together after the events of Thanos
in the Infinity Gauntlet saga and the
comics after Thanos collects all the
Infinity stones and all of the superhero
teams come together to fight against
Thanos and finally defeat him mr.
fantastic of the Fantastic Four would
ultimately go on to reveal that he's
been trying to collect the infinity gems
or Infinity stones as they call them in
the MCU and he takes this to the group
in hopes that they will help him collect
the Infinity stones
despite some apprehension by some of the
members in the group the Illuminati
manages to collect all of the Infinity
stones once the Illuminati collects all
of the Infinity stones mr. fantastic
tries to will the Infinity stones out of
existence but unfortunately he is unable
to do so mr. fantastic ends up getting a
reprimand from The Watcher wha - so what
mr. fantastic ends up deciding to do
along with the Illuminati is give won
infinity stone to each member of the
Illuminati to go and hide in the
universe it then becomes the sole
responsibility of that member of the
Illuminati to take care of each stone
they were assigned to now let's tie this
into Avengers infinity war and Avengers
end game everyone is now aware of
the Infinity stones are and what they
can do Fantas collected them all and
used them to erase half the population
from the universe just like he did in
the infinity goblin saga and obviously
the heroes of the world need to make
sure that this never happens again now
in Avengers in game it was revealed that
fan o's reduced the Infinity stones to
atoms however this does not mean that
they are destroyed in fact the Russo
brothers confirmed this in a Q&A
somebody asked them about the Infinity
stones being destroyed and they said the
Infinity stones aren't destroyed they
are simply reduced to atoms therefore
implying that the Infinity stones could
once again arise in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and this would make sense
because the time stone is of extreme
importance to Doctor Strange and in fact
in Avengers in game we learned from the
ancient one that if Doctor Strange does
not have the time stone his timeline and
reality is in grave danger in fact the
time stone is the only thing keeping
Dormammu away from Earth so it would
make sense that somehow Doctor Strange
and other members would find a way to
bring back at the Infinity stones but of
course obviously you would not want them
all in one place or even close to each
other so the Illuminati could be formed
and each member could be given an
infinity stone to look after or the
multiverse which we know dr. strange is
going to be dealing with in the
multiverse of madness could be used to
retrieve the Infinity stones as well so
Doctor Strange is going to form the
Illuminati and in the Illuminati is
going to be Professor Xavier this is
going to be his MCU debut setting up
future movies for the x-men and I
actually really like this way of
introducing mutants by introducing
Professor Xavier in Illuminati and
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness they are basically saying that
mutants have been around this whole
entire time and not only will this say
that they've been around the entire time
but this will also say that Doctor
Strange knew about them this could be a
really cool way to introduce them in the
MCU because we could get a little bit of
a backstory of what they were doing the
whole entire time during the Infinity
Saga they could explain where they were
during certain events like the Battle of
New York when Ultron came and of course
during infinity war and endgame and not
to mention that it could even be the
Eternals that step in and want the
Illuminati formed the Eternals were
created by the cosmic light gods the
Celestials and the Eternals his job
to protect earth and the humans we're
definitely going to find out where the
Eternals were and what they were doing
during the events of the nfinity saga
Kevin Feige has already confirmed this
he said that the Eternals know who the
Avengers are but the Avengers don't know
who the Eternals are they clearly didn't
intervene and step in during the events
of the Infinity Saga at least they
didn't make it known they could have
been operating behind the scenes but now
that Avengers endgame happened and the
earth and universe were almost destroyed
perhaps it's time for them to make
themselves known and this could be a
part of why the Illuminati are formed
because it's clear that Doctor Strange
is going to need help in protecting this
reality that the MCU existent and since
the Avengers are pretty much disbanded
right now and since new threats that are
going to be coming from extra
dimensional worlds are going to be
threatening the world it's time to call
in some of the most powerful beings and
existence Professor Xavier and mr.
fantastic now at this point in time it's
unknown of whether or not the Fantastic
Four are going to get their powers after
the events of Avengers in game or if
they've existed in the universe this
whole entire time as well but again
according to this inside scoop provided
by Mikey Sutton mr. fantastic and
Professor Xavier will be joining Doctor
Strange and the other members of the
Illuminati at the end of Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness be sure to
head over to Lords of the long boxes
youtube channel right now to discover
who else is going to be in the
Illuminati in the MCU I'll link them
down below and let me know what you
think about this news how excited are
you to see the Illuminati the mutants
and the Fantastic Four appear at the end
of Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness let me know what you think in
the comments down below and again
another thank you to mikey sutton for
letting me drop the scoop today don't
forget to subscribe with notifications
turned on like this video and leave a
comment below so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof